We now move to the case of
continuous random variables.
We will start with a special
case where we want to find the
PDF of a linear function of a
continuous random variable.
We will start by considering a
simple example, and study it
using an intuitive argument.
And afterwards, we will justify
our conclusions
mathematically.
So we start with a random
variable X that has a PDF over
the form shown in this figure
so that it is a piecewise
constant PDF.
We then consider a random
variable z, which is defined
to be 2 times X. The random
variable x takes values
between minus 1 and 1.
So z takes values between
minus 2 and 2.
Now, values of X between minus
1 and 0 correspond to values
of Z between minus 2 and 0.
The different values of X in
this range are, in some sense,
equally likely, because we
have a constant PDF.
And that argues that the
corresponding values of Z
should also be, in some
sense, equally likely.
So the PDF should be constant
over this range.
By a similar argument, the PDF
of Z should also be constant
over the range from 0 to 2.
And the PDF must, of course,
be 0 outside this range,
because these are values of
Z that are impossible.
Let us now try to figure out
the parameters of this PDF.
The probability that X
is positive is the
area of this rectangle.
And the area of this
rectangle is 2/3.
So the area of this rectangle
should also be 2/3.
And that means that the height
of this rectangle should be
equal to 1/3.
Similarly, the probability that
X is negative is the area
of this rectangle, and the
area of this rectangle is
equal to 1/3.
When X is negative, Z is also
negative, so the probability
of a negative value should
be equal to 1/3.
And for the area of this
rectangle to be 1/3, it means
that the height of this
rectangle should be 1/6.
So what happened here?
We started with a PDF of X and
essentially stretched it out
by a factor of 2 while keeping
the same shape.
However, we also scaled
it down by a
corresponding amount.
So 2/3 became 1/3, and
1/3 became 1/6.
The reason for this scaling down
is because we need the
total probability, the total
area under this PDF, to be
equal to 1.
If we now add a number, let's
say 3, to the random variable
Z, what is going to happen?
The random variable Y now
will take values from
minus 2 plus 3--
this is plus 1--
all the way up to 2 plus
3, which is plus 5.
Values in the range from 1 to 3
correspond to values of Z in
the range from minus 2 to 0.
These values are all, in some
sense, equally likely.
So they should also be
equally likely here.
And by a similar argument, these
values in the range from
3 to 5 should also be
equally likely.
This rectangle corresponds
to this rectangle here.
So the area should
be the same.
And therefore, the height
should also be the same.
Therefore, the height
here should be 1/6.
And by the same argument,
the height here
should be equal to 1/3.
So what happens here is that
when we add 3 to a random
variable, the PDF just gets
shifted by 3 but otherwise
retains the same shape.
So the story is entirely similar
to what happened in
the discrete case.
We start with a PDF of X. We
stretch it horizontally by a
factor of 2.
And then we shift it
horizontally by 3.
The only difference is that here
in the continuous case,
we also need to scale the plot
in the vertical dimension by a
factor of 2.
Actually, make it smaller
by a factor of 2.
And this needs to be done in
order to keep the total area
under the PDF equal to 1.
Let us now go through a
mathematical argument with the
purpose of also finding a
formula that represents what
we just did in our
previous example.
Let Y be equal to aX plus b.
Here, X is a random variable
with a given PDF.
a and b are given constants.
Now, if a is equal to 0, then
Y is identically equal to b.
So it is a constant random
variable and
does not have a PDF.
So let us exclude this case and
start by assuming that a
is a positive number.
We can try to work, as in the
discrete case, and try
something like the following.
The probability that Y takes
on a specific value is the
same as the probability that aX
plus b takes on a specific
value, which is the same as the
probability that X takes
on the specific value, y
minus b divided by a.
This equality was useful
in the discrete case.
Is it useful here?
Unfortunately not.
When we're dealing with
continuous random variables,
the probability that the
continuous random variable is
exactly equal to a given number,
this probability is
going to be equal to 0.
And the same applies to
this side as well.
So we have that 0
is equal to 0.
And this is uninformative, and
we have not made any progress.
So instead of working with
probabilities of individual
points which will always
be 0, we will work with
probabilities of intervals that
generally have non-zero
probability.
The trick is to work
with CDFs.
So let us try to find the CDF
of Y. The CDF of the random
variable Y is defined as the
probability that the random
variable is less than or equal
to a certain number.
Now, in our case,
Y is aX plus b.
We move b to the other side of
the inequality and then divide
both sides of the
inequality by a.
And we get that this is the same
as the probability that X
is less than or equal to y minus
b divided by a, which is
the same as the CDF of X
evaluated at y minus b over a.
So we have a formula for the CDF
of Y in terms of the CDF
of X.
How can we find the PDF?
Simply by differentiating.
We differentiate both sides
of this equation.
The derivative of
a CDF is a PDF.
And therefore, the PDF of Y is
going to be equal to the
derivative of this side.
Here we need to use
the chain rule.
First, we take the derivative
of this function.
And the derivative of the CDF
is a PDF, so the PDF of X
evaluated at this particular
number.
But then we also need to take
the derivative of the argument
inside with respect to y.
And that derivative
is equal to 1/a.
And this gives us a formula for
the PDF of Y in terms of
the PDF of X.
How about the case where
a is less than 0?
What is going to change?
The first step up to
here remains valid.
But now when we divide both
sides of the inequality by a,
the direction of the inequality
gets reversed.
So we obtain instead the
probability that X is larger
than or equal to y minus
b divided by a.
And this is 1 minus the
probability that X is less
than y minus b over a.
Now, X is a continuous random
variable, so the probability
is not going to change if here
we make the inequality to be a
less than or equal sign.
And what we have here is 1 minus
the CDF of X evaluated
at y minus b over a.
We use the chain rule once more,
and we obtain that the
PDF of Y, in this case, is equal
to minus the PDF of X
evaluated at y minus
b over a times 1/a.
Now, when a is positive,
a is the same as the
absolute value of a.
When a is negative and we have
this formula, we have here a
minus a, which is the same as
the absolute value of a.
So we can unify these two
formulas by replacing the
occurrences of a and that minus
sign by just using the
absolute value.
And this gives us this formula
for the PDF of Y in terms of
the PDF of X. And it is a
formula that's valid whether a
is positive or negative.
What this formula represents
is the following.
Because of the factor of a that
we have here, we take the
PDF of X and scale it
horizontally by a factor of a.
Because of the term b that we
have here, the PDF also gets
shifted horizontally by b.
And finally, this term here
corresponds to a vertical
scaling of the plot
that we have.
And the reason that this term is
present is so that the PDF
of Y integrates to 1.
It is interesting to also
compare with the corresponding
discrete formula that
we derived earlier.
The discrete formula has exactly
the same appearance
except that the scaling
factor is not present.
So for the case of continuous
random variables, we need to
scale vertically the PDF.
But in the discrete case, such
a scaling is not present.